he actually but he was a student a year
a year ago
now he's a young assistant professor at
uh bernard college so
mark did just give us a short uh demo
which we would
see as a poster or a talk where he will
tell more about
how uh he and uh is working and his
group and collaborators working
on optimizing uh cvc ford uh marketplace
sure um can everyone see the slides here
yes yes okay so all uh because we're
all virtual i decided the poster didn't
make so much sense so i'll just go
through some short slides
um and i'll talk about how we can use
neural networks to
assist with this uh syntax guided
synthesis
um and this is joint work between myself
uh
my advisor rujitsa um my office mate
bill and two
wonderful uh students who are now
undergraduates
um so we just saw andy's slide here
um and he mentioned that static grammar
minimization
is one aspect where there's some
space for optimization so i'll talk
about grammar minimization in
the context of using machine learning so
for those of you that didn't catch last
week's talk maybe just to review
sigis we have a saiga solver and we feed
it some specification and we get back
out code
so that specification consists of two
main parts constraints
and a grammar so let's take a look at a
specific
example so here this is in the sigis
language
a specification that says we'd like some
function
that maps hello to hello hello
so you can tell really easily here that
the function we're looking for is to
concatenate the
input with itself and indeed if we run
our solver then that's the function that
we're going to get
now what's interesting is if you take a
look at the grammar
we didn't actually need 90 percent of
this grammar we only needed a small
portion of it
so the question is can we predict ahead
of time what parts of the grammar we
don't need and
statically minimize that grammar in
order to shrink our search space
and so what we're going to do is try and
take our specification and then
construct a filtered grammar
so to do this we're going to have to
introduce three different
components for this grammar prediction
we're going to
introduce criticality and this is saying
how likely
is it that a particular terminal is part
of the
grammar that we need for this particular
function so this is where we're learning
something about the semantics of the
scigis language
then we also need to predict the time
and what's interesting is that
predicting the time
is solver specific so we're actually
trying to use machine learning here to
predict something
about that particular solver and the way
it explores its terms
and then we'll combine these two metrics
to
filter out our grammar so we have three
main components here
our criticality where we're building a
map
between i o examples and for this whole
presentation i'm focusing just on
programming by example
for scigis i'll talk a little bit about
how that's a restriction
but we're trying to create a map between
i o
examples and terminals and say what's
the probability that this
grammar terminal is required for solving
a sigis query in that describes this
io programming by example uh constraint
and then for predicting time we're
saying okay just in general
how much time does it add to our solver
if we include this new terminal so if we
were to remove this terminal from the
grammar
let's say we're using cvc4
how much time could we save by removing
this terminal from the grammar ahead of
time
and then to combine these we're going to
take our prediction for the probability
of criticality
and then the time saved over the size of
the grammar and
filter out our grammars so three main
questions are what's the probability of
terminal is critical for this particular
constraint
what's the estimated time saved by
removing this particular terminal
and then we finally ask of the terminals
that save the most time by being removed
which are the least likely to be
critical
now this is just a poster presentation
so i won't get into all three of these
but i'll talk a little bit about this
first one
criticality and the key question here is
how we obtain training data for this so
we're going to be using a neural network
and i'm sure everyone's heard the basic
story behind neural networks by now
we feed it some training data and then
we can give it more down and it's going
to give us a prediction
so here our training data is going to be
sets triplets of input output examples
the input and the output as well as the
terminal
mapped to whether or not the boolean
value of whether or not that terminal
was critical for that example
so in order to generate this data set we
take three steps first
we generate functions from the grammar
and we use this enumerative solver that
andy was just talking about zygas
cvc4 we use specifically because it's so
beautifully engineered and so easy to
use
um and in particular there's one
flag sigis stream which will just stream
all the possible functions that meet the
constraints
and if we run scigix stream with a
grammar with no constraints we can just
enumerate through all of the
possible functions of that grammar
and then we're going to apply for each
function we're going to apply that
function to some randomly generated
inputs so as an example here we
take this third function
x plus x plus x and we say okay we're
just going to give it some
inputs and outputs and then
we're going to build what's called a one
hot vector
this is a sort of machine learning thing
and it just says
we want to count up how many times
[Music]
the terminals were used for this example
set
so for the example our triplet here is
going to be rand
and then rand rand rand will be the
second part of the triplet and the third
part of the triplet
will be the set plus plus uh string plus
plus and that's going to map to one and
then
everything else all the other terminals
are going to map to zero because we
didn't require
any of the other grammar terminals uh
for synthesizing a function that meets
this constraint
so once we've built this we build what's
called the one hot vector
and then we can pipe this through a
normal
[Music]
neural network we use something called a
feed forward network
but actually this is not a critical part
of this
um so quickly hop to the evaluation then
because we've only got five minutes here
so we looked at
sigis comp which is the sigis
competition
rajiv was telling us a bit about this
within the saiges competition there's a
number of different
tracks i think there's five tracks in
2019
and the pve strings track is one of
those
so programming by example for strings
there's 64 examples
and solvers get an hour to solve each
problem
and so we ask can our grammar reduction
tool grt here
uh working with cvc4 outperform cvc4 by
itself and the short answer is yes
uh 47 percent faster
to add this reduction grammar reduction
tool in front of cvc4
what's really and so you can see this is
just a selection of some of those
uh benchmarks which had a reduced time
what's really interesting is that when
we only consider
um the criticality when we're only
predicting whether or not a terminal is
critical
to the grammar and we don't take into
account the timing data
synthesis succeeds on only 11 out of the
64 benchmarks
so the idea here is if you're removing a
terminal from your grammar you want to
be really sure that you're actually
going to
save time with this because the risk
that you run of course by removing the
terminal from the grammar
is that synthesis can no longer succeed
because your grammar is too small
so sort of the key insight here is you
need to actually consider both how much
time you're going to save what's the
reward as well as what is the risk
so we saw in 32 out of 64 benchmarks
we were faster and there was even one
benchmark which was timing out with cvc4
which were able to actually solve within
the timeout
the standard timeout of the saiges
competition with
our grammar reduction tool
so there's a lot of really interesting
future directions you might look at this
and say 46
faster oh maybe we're done that's as
good as machine learning is going to get
but i think there's a lot of space here
um
so uh the key insight so far is just
that we need to
account for not only the criticality but
the time savings
but if we're looking more generally
maybe there's some more sophisticated
time prediction heuristics
as a reminder we only looked at one
terminal
how that terminal behaves across all
sorts of different
constraints for that tool but we might
be able to
have a more fine-grained time prediction
also each example is encoded separately
so we were only looking at programming
by example
and we saw we looked at each program
each constraint programming by example
constraint
individually and then gave that to the
neural network that doesn't account for
any interaction between the constraints
so we might be able to learn something
more if we looked at how the
input output examples interact with each
other
the other question of course is so far
we only looked at strings
strings as it turns out are very easy to
encode in
a neural network but as we start
branching out to integers bit vectors
and data types
the encoding process becomes a bit more
complicated
and additionally we were only looking at
programming by example
and so the question is how many but of
course zygus in general
and cvc4 supports more general first
order logic constraints
um and so how might we encode these
logic constraints into the neural
network is
instead as well as the programming by
example
so if you'd like to read more we had a
paper at this
at triple ai last year this was actually
in february last year right before
everything went south um the code is
also online
um so i'd encourage you to take a look
at this and the other thing i just want
to point out is that there
was some interesting work that came out
a bit after this
on a similar problem that extended the
idea of using
machine learning to pre-prune the
grammar
that was more general than just looking
at program by example constraints and so
maybe we can even hear a bit about that
from our next speaker
okay uh thank you mark that was couple
of minutes more
uh i can we can allow only one
quick question if there is some
uh let's see
and i do it has to be quick
what about transformers for this dog
yeah there's there's so we were looked
at
really the most basic neural network
which is just a feed forward network
um and we we had a lot of questions
about this on the review as well because
we submitted to triple ai whether it's a
lot of machine learning people so
there's a lot of other techniques out
there that might be
more effective um i think the
sort of thing and we definitely don't
have the most efficient
neural network structure yet i think the
key point here is just that
if you're going to do some pre-filtering
you need to think about two things not
just how critical the
grammar elements are but also how much
time you're going to save
yeah so it looks to me like you need
some kind of attention mechanism in this
i mean
that might be kind of and that's what
transformer also have self-attention and
you know and you can think of it also as
a you take a grammar and you generate a
new grammar
like you know like a translation thing
so
uh i think there is some some i don't
know whether it would help but
uh there might be some potential here i
have to look at it possibly yeah
a lot of space there yeah very nice
very nice by the way
thank you too but we really need to take
a short break now
let's start whenever is your time zone
at o5
and elizabeth if you're there let's make
sure that your slides are working right
now
yeah great thank you mark